[Music]
we're lucky to be in the city book to
movie adaptation that's a narrow reading
candor value honesty and order they tell
the truth ironically this seems like a
completely subjective faction to find
oneself in how do you greet someone's
truth-telling skills do they line up a
whole bunch of cliche 1980s sitcom moms
and ask if this dress makes him look fat
we even feed the factionless futuristic
society is evolved were homeless into
factionless trust the test tests will
tell me who I am
we interrupt this Hunger Games ripoff to
bring you the sorting hat ceremony from
Harry Potter I'm a smart kind by honest
selfless this word only kind of means
selfless if you're reaching a bit aren't
there dictionaries in the future they
should have called the dauntless faction
Dix dauntless are daunted by doors
failed the test immediately it is your
right tomorrow
the choosing ceremony to choose any of
the five factions including the
truth-telling one even if you're the
worst lying liar in libel what society
says we're gonna break you up into
factions because it works now you can be
whatever you want even if it's wrong so
wait there's a technician for every
single person getting tested right now
that's an amazing ratio and what faction
are the technicians in shailene woodley
is once again not playing Mary Jane
Watson in this movie Wow
I didn't read the book so I wasn't sure
what to expect then people said it was
kind of a Hunger Games ripoff but Jesus
she is literally running after a rabid
dog in order to save cats his little
sister right now this is a crossover by
chance what was the result
abnegation I narrow tight and dauntless
but not truthful enough to be in candor
you lying whore not impossible it's just
extremely rare so it's extremely rare
for anyone to show more than one trait
these people are human right they call
it divergent roll credits you can't tell
anyone about this but I'm freely telling
you this for some reason because there's
no way a divergent kid like you is gonna
go telling people about your abilities
and showing them off in any way if you
explain the danger to her and manually
entered a false result for her test then
why do you have to rush her out the back
again oh you died they believe that they
should be the governing faction not us
well we have an argument right I mean
sure you're the generous caring type
here in navigation but they're way
smarter and more logical than you right
it's at least not an open-and-shut case
that you guys should be doing the ruling
honestly I'm kind of wondering how you
abnegation folk ever came to power
anyway how did you pull yourself away
from feeding homeless people enough to
pry the government away from the cops
and dauntless Tris looks at a reflection
in the spoon which some
Eliza's Hearn on abnegation Asst but I
choose to believe there is no spoon but
you don't this is the first inkling of
defiance in this chick up until now
she's been quiet cautious downright
sheepish today though she's a back
talking little scamp holy shit they're
doing this one by one
I hope these kids brought an iPhone that
last 24 hours the choosing ceremony is a
dick to the guy that has to sanitize
this knife after every choice we saw her
brother choose the water one with his
blood drop and Beatrice goes right after
him so did they swap out the bowls for
each choice - there's no blood in any of
these things but the ceremony's been
going on long enough that they should
all be covered in disgusting bloodstains
now that she's with dauntless how will
she ever find a seat for the remaining
127 hours of this ceremony okay so this
dauntless dude gives up his seat so how
long he ever find a seat for the
remaining 127 hours of this ceremony wow
this ragtag bunch of kids aren't
deterred by anything they're fearless
they're basically dauntless oh wait is
this all these dauntless people do run
and climb on because how does that help
Society the inclusion of a Kravitz
proves this movie is in no way trying to
avoid Hunger Games comparisons get ready
get ready is a pretty useless piece of
information if you aren't also gonna
tell us what to get ready for like get
ready to jump or get ready to have a
dance party together man this train is
taking forever to pass this building at
least is so much time they should have
missed their chance but plot I guess one
at our dauntless this is the way in so
they're not already dauntless I have to
choose a faction potentially alienate
their parents and then jump off a moving
train but that's not very loose enough
for you people and so what kind of test
to the other factions give their new
recruits do they only have secondary
tests in candor are they like what is
your favorite color red no yellow don't
they want acetone again my thoughts
exactly
but having a character in the movie say
it doesn't mean it erases the sin after
the first one jumps that shouldn't be
nearly the daunting task they set this
up to be right my name is for luck you
mean we're gonna have to go through all
that I am Number Four bull again the
first listen euler for me
let's keep your mouth shut in other
words when you join dauntless it's time
to be daunted when it comes to running
your mouth
dauntless has a mysterious system of
integrating new recruits so that we the
audience can avoid learning too early
dauntless faction takes their name way
too seriously and extends its symbolism
to the phone bathroom scene does not
contain nudity lap dances or reason to
live
were you a transfer to or don't let's
play what makes you think you can talk
to me because you're sitting in the
cafeteria with your subordinates also if
this is supposed to be some sort of
military these assholes have done a poor
job
the rules to the new recruits we believe
in ordinary acts of bravery in the
courage that's Rives one person to stand
up for one other but we act like
assholes to each other for some reason
welcome to the faction crowd-surfing 1
everyone in the pit 2 minutes 2 minutes
is not enough time to do anything let
alone wake up also new rules guys was
bring to each other main characters
divergent and she shouldn't say anything
about it can we going to expose the
Hunger Games Catching Fire portion of
this story it'll save us so many trips
to the movie theater sweating running
you know a lesser man would make a
catfight reference here is this where
the other failed dauntless go to become
tattoo artists how convenient for
Beatrice that the medical woman who
performed her test and saved her life
mysteriously is also a tattoo artist by
night Society if you don't fit into a
category they can't control you I don't
get it yeah you and me both babe this
challenge to a character played by a
somewhat named actress means that she
will easily pass this test with flying
colors and there's no suspense at all
sorry time what was that a moment of
silence or something I'm gonna guess
that most people could have hung there
for the time she did do you know let's
just say they built the French for a
reasonable characters vague about the
danger outside the fence because the
movie needs to keep the audience in the
dark
also Game of Thrones much for some
reason well go get it well while they're
throwing are you afraid everybody stop
stand in front of the target just cut
this asshole already if you think he
can't hack it why on earth would
dauntless set up their training this way
it's fucking preposterous
just cut the slackers and train the
others like regular modern soldiers do
training what about the future requires
the training AQAP's to be overly
emasculating and legitimately deadly a
marcus and the other local faction
leadership aware that the entire
dauntless faction has essentially
devolved into a sadistic magic show oh
those mockingjays hey Tris I was cool
now we're robbing Harry Potter for the
dickhead kid mocks protagonists
regarding newspaper articles and rumors
about them
this book may be fantastic I'll never
know but the movie is about as original
as a forgery isn't for actually
endangering Tris more by so obviously
giving her special treatment and advice
in front of everyone else
and in front of the asshole guy well I
don't want to piss anyone off at least
not any more than normal so ladies that
the audience I ask you is this society
feminist or sexist it's not like she has
a chance against someone who is as much
faster and stronger as basically any
average male initiate would be so it's
not fair but it's equal right train
never makes any increases
acceleration and is easily tracked down
by a coma patient because divergent the
James simple slide capture-the-flag
movie turns into Unreal Tournament which
isn't as soon except with the fact that
this movie won't let me play I'll take
the stiff looking the weak once you
guess I'm gonna blame them you lose or
he just wants to fucker are you paying
attention to anything also an hour into
the movie and we're still just playing
games
thinking no one else thought of this I
am seriously beginning to doubt the
efficacy of dauntless his current
training program sexy ladder break they
were up on that fucking high ass fence
just a little bit ago and he didn't show
any signs of trouble then meanwhile all
other ladder rungs are sturdy ish but I
guess we can't fault the latter for
playing from cupid just this once it
rarely gets to see people anymore oh I
think they might guess meanwhile all the
rest of four squad of inexperienced
initiate sizz just standing down there
doing nothing or watching these two and
Eric's squad isn't doing any attacking
or anything tell me if this hurts
futuristic assholes still haven't
learned a thing and still say stuff
before shooting people wait this game
really is capture the flag so why did
four tell everyone like capture the flag
when it's actually capture the flag not
telling new recruits about all the crazy
twists and turns in this zipline and
telling them to pull the brig at the end
without telling them what the end looks
like yep dauntless continued to be dicks
movies concept of time is really
beginning to piss me off
I guess this person is calling a secret
meeting what better way to do that than
shining a fucking mirror everyone can
see also of course nobody sees this
because in movies no one has peripheral
vision and everyone is completely
focused on their mindless tasks also all
supervisors decide to look the other way
as one of their own walks behind a
wallet palettes what is this place
what's in these sacks do you care no of
course not we just need to let her have
some weirdo conversation with her mom
you Tallis
hey the guard somehow doesn't see
Chris's mom when he comes around the
corner basically that's the movie
telling us that the guard yelled hey
before you even got around the corner
which is not only stupid but hilarious
fortunately Patricia the person
administering the fear test that would
likely reveal her true divergent nature
is the dude that has already shown her
tons of favoritism he's touched her
awkwardly more times than I can count
now we get it they're gonna bone let's
get to that already I'm gonna be facing
your worst fears Tris we interrupt this
fuckin Frankenstein of a cliche written
movie to bring you the face your worst
fear thing from Jesus I don't know at
least a dozen better films that came out
before this one
oh this movie really is longer games
Trista's first worst fear is
dive-bombing birds
I guess abnegation faction decided to
show the birds to the young children
shouldn't her worst fear hallucination
basically be her in a public square
wearing and I'm a divergent t-shirt I
just want to know how she does it what's
your trick everyone in this movie knows
what divergent means but can't quite
seem to come out and say it or suggests
or suspect that she might be divergent
Thomas don't break the glass like that
isn't what he's trying to say nobody
breaks the glass like that what does it
matter if dauntless don't break the
glass this way by her own admission
she's not dauntless she defected so what
does the statement really prove tattoo
mystery woman who was either not willing
to talk or super nervous about it both
prior appearances has given up the ghost
and is now willing to just calmly tell
Chris all the helpful information she
knows why because the story is ready for
- that's why you think that human nature
is weakness girl who knows it's standing
out and challenging Authority is the
fastest way to getting her divergent is
discover and keep standing out by
challenging Authority I think human
nature is the enemy
so Christianity without the gala been
you're aware that abnegation is
undermining the faction system they're
breaking laws harboring divergence why
the fuck is evil kate winslet telling
her all this why does she believe
Trista's in any way special or in a
position to help her on the other hand
if he knows or suspects that chris is
divergent why bother telling her all
this and then letting her go three dudes
who had no trouble bringing her here
suddenly don't have the power to throw
her into the pit of death oh come on she
can pull the guys mask off and stare
dramatically into his eyes but still not
get thrown into the pit by these other
two people clock tower ex machina Wow
wait so attempted murders amongst
initiates are tolerated you should lie
down get some food
thank you for we definitely don't need
to report the fact that several of your
fellow initiates just trying to kill you
he was not gonna press that final test
yeah they're mine why do you say that
this guy is either the densest
motherfucker in history or else he's
known she's divergent all this time and
just refuses to talk about it because
the screenwriter forbade him either way
it's a sin because I'm sick of it you're
gonna practice in my fair landscape No
divergent section also fear landscape
and this movie is one I am your father
revelation away from literally being the
most cliche movie I've ever seen Marcus
had a son and that is one of the least
satisfying and arbitrary origin stories
for someone's fake name I've ever heard
if they were truly dauntless they'd
right now or at least strip I don't want
to go too fast yeah going too fast is
what those amedy sluts do come on in -
voiceover hey that's exactly what he
said to get her into the bed if I'm too
good then they'll kill me and if I'm too
slow then all died right but don't worry
you practice this one time with me in a
simulation that is not going to be the
one you're about to do now so you should
pass with flying colors oh look the city
of Chicago otherwise known as
coincidental timing city has once again
brought this tattoo artist and tryst
together are they testing every single
initiative every single faction one at a
time like this even if it's only every
single dauntless initiate this process
would take ages like longer than that
bolt choosing ceremony even I can't they
see more than this isn't this a program
of some sort
where the whole area is mapped out
wouldn't they be able to see everything
and not just this camera angle shot and
hi dream Edition how is this even a
final exam this is the exact same
simulation if you practice this over and
over which apparently these recruits do
then this will be no challenge at all
even if the goal was to figure out if
they're divergent why not make the
simulation a surprise why don't we do it
divergent
how did that asshole pass the Dauntless
test did he have someone dreamy holding
his hand through the whole process like
Tris and if so why is he so dumb that's
probably the convenience he gives to the
plot it's my guess is this what
snowpiercer would be like if we got to
see it from the other science point of
view oh man
I hope she didn't get caught even though
she and the audience have already been
informed that these people are just
drones now and don't process information
like they used to and there's no danger
or suspense at all this we're both
scared moment brought to you by the
committee for making movies longer than
they need to be I think you might be
overestimating my character what is your
character exactly
abnegation if left unchecked will
destroy the faction system then kill
them already we will restore the peace
and this time it will last you haven't
shown me one King scene of civil unrest
or anything opposite of peace among
these citizens for this entire movie yet
he's an insubordinate no-good dirty
divergent better punch him instead of
shooting him that's what I say yeah
let's do this at a private place there's
no need to make this public even though
all the execution so far have been
public the irony is that by trying to
build suspense in this way you basically
do the opposite instead of shooting her
right away which would make the most
sense these idiots take their sweet time
because protagonist and because they
took 20 seconds to not shoot
mommy's bullets get to save the day good
thing they decided to try and execute
her here instead of in front of the
houses or else Tris would be formed also
those dudes must have been Louisville
Cardinal fans all of these guys got done
masturbating and decided to finally show
up after their buddies got shot thank
goodness for Tris that will is a
stormtrooper honestly how did he score
high enough to make dauntless with aim
this terrible
Tris skills will one guy and suddenly
the coast is clear oh no her mother's
not gonna die is she
killers can't hear Tris crying about her
mom and don't go in for the old two easy
kill and what the shooting at anyway
what now not gonna like it you're not
gonna like a cliche thankfully the movie
makes sure one of the random dauntless
guys she comes across happens to be the
asshole from her initiate class movie
really really wants Tris to have dead
parents you know its climax time because
the mind-controlling sim machine and all
the characters are all in the same room
the brilliance of the faction system is
the conformity to the faction removes
the threat of anyone exercising your
independent well well except for you
right
how do any other people following her
take her seriously divergents threaten
that system good god the total lack of
killing pris and massive amounts of
exposition being given at the end of
this movie is fucking exhausting oh
she's gonna talk him out of it now I
know you're in there for what is he doc
ock four breaks out of his simulation
brainwashing because the power of boners
is stronger okay so there are four other
people in this room after this one shot
he should be riddled with bullets right
right after running out of bullets four
gets lucky and everyone else in the
building suddenly doesn't have a gun
right the security cam cuts directly to
Tris his former best friend right in
this moment of course it does
I admire you willing to die for what you
believe but it's all not make out with
her already oh snap now tryst is gonna
have to show these people the world
without robots a world without rules and
controls Without Borders or boundaries a
world where anything is possible
don't get me wrong there's a certain
Beauty resistance pink protagonist
repeats words previously spoken to them
only this time with irony cliche and
these are words Jeanine just fucking
said five minutes ago and this is where
you realize this is gonna end on a
cliffhanger making it no better than an
episode of MacGyver
you know how do you know you woke up
from your brainwashing kicked some ass
and then started running you couldn't
possibly know this no faction well
there's always district 13 wait I know
exactly who you are
oh good could you feel awesome but we
found ourselves and each other
narration again just like in the opening
minute and now no narration whatsoever
in between perfection this movie would
have made a great intro instead we get
what is it three or four books in this
bloated mess of a series I guess that
means a total of five more movies then
ranked Stanford the target ever since
cinemasins began the most requested
thing has been TV since and now it's a
reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
[Music]
remember the enemy has only images and
illusions behind which he hides his true
motives destroy the image and you will
break the enemy they call it divergent
it's a condition of mental diverges I
find myself on the planet Olga part of
an intellectual elite right okay
Gryffindor Slytherin a spell with chalk
wizard who went bad he wasn't in
Slytherin the first lesson you learned
from me you do not talk about like this
is the pit center of life here at Delos
[Music]
and then there's dauntless how the
dullness is the power in these waters
true enough
dauntless never give up never give up
never points for bravery stick not as
many as you just lost for opening your
mouth watch yourself my whole body was
covered in these little insects they're
in my ears they're my throat I couldn't
breathe yeah they were nice you know and
like you grab a woman's breast it feels
like a bag of sand see Katniss the way
the whole friend thing works is you have
to tell each other the deep stuff it
deep stuff ya know like what like watch
your favorite color when you've stepped
over the line